we're currently the only entertainment
center that is basically like a hybrid
PC console VR and laser tag all under
one roof we're basically the first ones
in Sioux Falls to introduce to virtual
reality to the community
they actually are now training to
perform surgeries in virtual reality
they're actually virtual reality
simulator right now a billboard you can
purchase such game slash experience for
as long as you have the we are set up at
our store one of the most popular games
right now still us the job simulator
this is where it's gonna explode
probably if if not already exploding is
the entertainment industry which is
where we are at right now the market is
oversaturated with the cheap or
absolutely free games and right now
there are two free games that just
dominate the rest of the games fortnight
and epics legends there are so many
distribution systems now - like back in
the days should steam 14 years ago it
was just steam obviously the
communication I teamwork would be the
biggest one biggest benefits in gaming
but of course the motor skills as well
depending on what kind of games you're
playing of course so it's more than just
entertainment we even have some
businesses coming in to do it a team
work and they actually play video games
together like they separate and groups
and only play against each other they
live with memories they live experiences
something that they haven't before
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sack young we are on
site in the beautiful Sioux Falls South
Dakota
we are now going to be talking about
galaxy gaming we have max tough to not
see joining us on the show hi max hello
thank you so much for coming on the show
and it's look very pumped to talk to you
for those who don't know Max's
background he's the founder of galaxy
gaming which is a laser tag virtual
reality and social gaming center in
Sioux Falls South Dakota they're
approaching their 14th anniversary you
find the links in the bio below the
galaxy gaming comm as well as their
Instagram Facebook and Twitter pages all
right max let's start things off by
asking you one of our favorite questions
like what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world if I only knew
the answer to that I don't think anybody
knows to be honest it it's it's it's
hard to tell and like we can all see the
technology evolving and it's going
really fast especially like what what
I've noticed the virtual reality
introduction it did take off a lot they
might not see it at the households but
definitely it gets very popular in all
sorts of industries military science
health industry you name it yeah the
rapid pace of technological change is
occurring it's being democratized
computing power is increasing yet our
our biological this inner art that is
our bodies that we have yet to really
spiritually
that well it's kind of like this do you
ever feel like that's a little bit of
like a struggle that we haven't even
figured out our own like spiritual
divinity and we're like already trying
to upload our consciousness oh it's a
little bit too soon to upload yeah
thanks I mean I don't think we're it you
know we're there yet but we're trying to
go to the virtual worlds and one yeah
yeah yes that is very true
I may be just like the way to escape the
reality so to speak but yeah for like
the gaming industry itself the
businesses as usual you just seem more
like a high resolutions more partly guns
maybe more power-ups in the games if
we're talking about the game in of
course in virtual reality I would say
like when it comes to the game inside I
don't really know much about everything
else I mean I know in the military
they're now doing training so you you
can you can learn how to fly the jet
without ever sitting in one basically
yes almost same kind of scenario goes
with with a health industry they
actually are now training to perform
surgeries in virtual reality they're
actually virtual reality simulator right
now available you can you can even
purchase such game / experience for as
long as you have the they are set up and
you can play that like for instance us
like at our store one of the most
popular games right now still use the
job simulator the job simulator yep we
win that one
there is a few different things you can
do in there like it usually starts out
with a job at fast-food place which
which can be pretty fun and funny
because kids always mess around they're
like they don't necessarily do what they
were supposed to be doing but yeah you
can actually cook in that game
it looks very cartoonish it's not
looking like the most impressive game
even though there are some impressive
games very immersive but for some odd
reason they're not the most played games
at the store your focus on virtual
reality and that being just opening up
insane amounts of possibilities and it
already is being applied in so many
industries like you said where do you
see that you know as it becomes
democratized as more and more people
take augmented and virtual realities for
their work life so it you know becomes
basically a part of what we do every
single day it increases creative ability
when I don't have to use this this
laptop but instead I can just have a
beautiful 3d space in front of me that I
can just go and edit video in and be
creative in where do you see that all
going even like the time frame wise and
like experience wise like on a daily
basis we're all gonna be in those
environments engaging with each other
well I can tell you this much we're not
gonna see that anytime soon
[Music]
maybe a decade from now there is a
possibility of that like if you if you
want to have photorealistic graphics
quality right now currently it's kind of
sort of possible in Indy are it just of
course you're gonna have some
limitations to that because there is a
hardware limitation the game developers
for instance they can they have to cut
corners right now so they can make a
more realistic graphics but it'll be a
much smaller space where you're going to
be able to see all that graphic
and vice-versa like you wanna have like
a bigger world the graphic is gonna have
to be done scaled so like in in in our
store we we do have some graphics crude
graphics cards installed in VR systems
that are pretty much the top of the line
and you can play some graphics and
tennis games already but I would also
say even those cards do struggle so one
nice thing about VR this is where it's
gonna explode probably if if not already
exploding is the entertainment industry
which is where we're at right now for
the noticing more and more bigger
companies are coming to this market is
book buying oculus yeah but that one
like and that that sort of news is more
towards you know like it's more about
the households individuals I'm talking
about more like more a lot more serious
era which you cannot obtain at home
we're talking about like
commercial-grade
oh yeah yeah like the ones in like
Hollywood where they're doing some great
things around like doing like volumetric
capture and like a human or like an
object yeah yeah computer grab the
collar which is the Hollywood is
actually use them using this to do the
film in like navigates eighty percent of
all current film is already CGI there's
a good chance of that you can probably
see some videos for the people are like
covered in a net they have this like a
sensors on the bodies so that's that's
how the user VR and in that regard and
they have to use a very expensive
cameras which are very hard to obtain
just because of the costs due to the red
cameras or which cameras are it's a
special capturing capture
hardware gamers basically and the
resolution is insane there so that
that's why you can't just like buy one
of those pieces for home we're talking
about hundreds of thousands of dollars
here for the equipment but the companies
are making it more affordable for
businesses currently even though it's
still like I mean the prices I do know
some of the prices for some of the
commercial they are systems it can go as
high as four hundred fifty thousand
dollars for a set up which would not
make a lot of sense in a smaller
communities but we are in a smaller
community so we have to we have to look
for something that's more like
competitive price wise and there are
solutions like that so like right now
the system that we have it's not a
commercial type of like a commercial
grade of a setup because the software is
not like a third not like a proprietary
software that were using when it comes
to the commercial grade ones they
usually develop the game specifically
for the hardware that they supply and
that type of software slash games you
can't replicate anywhere else so you
can't you can't obtain this for fro home
doesn't matter how much money you're
gonna spend on your system you just
won't be able to access it because the
library like subscription to those can
cost tens tens of thousands of dollars
annually so that's something to keep in
mind
so then is a lot of what is right now
being used at the edge by like Hollywood
and other major organizations that are
able to afford this equipment that's
slowly being democratized it seems like
more and more we're gonna see CGI being
used these like volumetric capture of a
human and then me being able to like
just click and drag you through an
actual like virtual reality and then
also throwing objects in there that have
been volumetrically captured and then me
just being able to make whole videos
from just completely digitally yeah
they're libraries the problem with all
the things you just described is the
power like you you have to have enough
power in your hardware to to perform all
those activities and it's simply not
possible currently there is a few I
would almost say like a gimmicky
hardware pieces that are available but
there are more they're designed more for
like entertainment for more than
anything basically the challenge for the
VR currently to bring it to the public
in general here's the hardware like what
would be convenient for you to use we're
talking about the glasses or we're
talking about like a headset I mean I
just don't picture somebody we're going
around and wearing a headset on the
street the contact lens contact lens
maybe but then what's gonna render all
all the graphics for you I've G biology
the that brain is the problem as well
there was numbers of companies that
tried basically installing the rendering
Hardware somewhere like basically
somewhere remote the idea behind it was
let's say you just using your laptop to
game you just have to connect to to this
company server which would be rendering
all the graphics but unfortunately it
does not work you have to have some and
basically that's not remote even right
now it's actually pretty challenging
because even even right now for example
HD cyf Pro sets like a VR sets they do
offer the option of going completely
wireless basically it's called a free
roaming experience and the problem with
that one is
yes school like you did basically you
have to install the battery on top of
your set and you're connected via Wi-Fi
to the computer a computer has to be in
close proximity still and the problem is
even over Wi-Fi and when and why five is
a much stronger than you know like ran
in your random internet connection so
even over Wi-Fi there is a bandwidth
problem there is a bandwidth limits
because you can tell like when when you
where in that you can tell that the
graphics aren't as great and all the
sudden you have a latency switch legs
yeah so he will be noticed all of that
for now wired verse wireless so like
today I mean it's possible to to make I
think a Microsoft has a I think it's
called hololens in the holidays to you
you have they've been toying with this
idea it's extremely expensive i things
about three thousand three five thousand
dollars yeah and it's not even as as
good as you would imagine like it's
nowhere near close to an actual VR
headset first of all yeah she acted as a
are is really cool yeah yeah that one is
kind of like cool idea to have it and of
course the they had to overcome some
obstacles like the power of the hardware
again they have to simplify the graphics
so the graphics are very simple on that
it's like in our entertainment industry
I am not sure how good that is what are
the other current applications that the
kids and adults are coming into galaxy
gaming to use the VR for you gave the
idea that is the current one of the
current applications is like they can
get behind like this job simulator which
is kind of interesting the kids don't
like figure out like maybe I am
interested in this like healthcare field
or maybe I am interested in this
technology field or whatever it is so
what are the other things that people
are using the
people mainly coming up of course the
main the main reason they come in as
they come in for entertainment yeah so
they come in to have fun they come in to
escape boring reality which sometimes is
the case here in our city depending on
whether we do have to make a lot of your
own fun in football yeah
yes I mean some people even come in to
use the vacation simulator game vacation
Co there is again a small vacation
simulator so you basically are out
somewhere in the beach in VR of course
that's not the main reason people come
in but it's not mean game the people
want to play in VR but of course one of
the nice things about VR games is gamers
our there a lot or merciful yeah
so you do feel like you're actually
there and there are new saying so like a
lot of people played on our location for
the first time they've never played VR
before or if or if they did it would
have been VR glasses for 10 bucks
so yeah yes my water for a smartphone VR
which is I mean II can't even compare
those so it's good you're opening them
to the what it's it would be interesting
to see what if you're like wearing an
each year so you're like mapping your
neural activity and then like a child
gets exposed to virtual reality and just
to be able to like catalog what happened
to the brain during that experience
because if I bet a lot of creative
thoughts occur like whoa what are we
gonna be able to do with this technology
yeah that's true another one fun and
actually in the occasional educated
experience is Google via Google of they
are you ever heard about that one before
Google Earth we are oh that yeah cool
that one is recognizes it's
photorealistic graphics and you can go
to any place on a plane basically that's
like you can explore you can see there
different countries before you even go
there
if you decide you can drop into March
you and Michael yes yeah stuff like that
that's really cool it is he and widow
with a nice set of hardware it does look
pretty realistic like it's a nice set of
hardware you don't need to fly yeah that
is true we did we did have some some
some grandma came in she is from UK she
just wanted to see her homeland without
like it's really hard for her to travel
yeah
so that was one interesting time when
somebody used it for that basically just
to to see the places where she's been
like a really long time ago and she just
um due to some health issues see as I'm
able to go there it's a cool use case
yeah yeah I bet she had a lot of fun
doing that and connecting back to her
childhood in those locations yeah it's
fun even for me like and to visit like
to see different landscapes countries
yeah anywhere that was really really fun
I do it obsessively on the 2d some
computers although I do it obsessively I
love Google Earth so mmm you have to be
able to go in 3d I mean to be able to
see the different places in the world
and understand how geographies have
evolved and cultures have evolved you
know what what their environments look
like not very many places outside of
suburban United States look like the
suburban United States yeah yeah that's
very true another one thing that's worth
noting about virtual reality is it's
different basically it's very different
from gaming first of all the the crowd
that comes into play we are is not gamer
crowd so to speak like it's not it's not
the same people that come in and play
video games all day or for hours at the
store it's basically a very different
type of activity in a way some of the
games there they do require a lot of
physical activity in the way it's almost
like working out
there are boxing games there is a using
music games the bit saver we are where
you actually have to slash cubes in a
proper like rhythm isms yes so those
those will make your words away yes
that's good for your health it is
putting up so and it figure people care
and it's actually like one of the nice
things it's actually it's really fun I
was kinda out of breath once when I was
actually doing a boxing game and you
actually have to like really put a lot
of force into like punches there because
the camera can see when you just like
you know waving your hands or you
actually like really trying to go so so
the the camera can sense it so you
cannot really achieve that that's cool
so you do have to put a lot of a lot of
effort out of our different crowds
different drugs yeah I would say when we
were first introduced and we are here in
town we thought it was gonna be
gamers coming in but to our surprise it
was more of a couple's for the date
nights either usually before going to
the movie or after going to the movie
because we are obviously we we
communicate we talk to people just like
how they came about and like how what
kind of games they like and we would
normally find out that there is a movie
that's going on but they wanted to
someone before that and they are allows
you just there because you can have a
lot of fun and even in 15 minutes yeah
in a gaming you would normally need a
lot more like to start one game when
what time it's done is gonna be like 40
minutes or so a VR offers you a lot
shorter games they do have games that
are appealing for families and we get a
lot of families as well we have a lot of
parents coming in with what their
children there is a game that's called
loco dojo it's pretty much some Mario
Party in virtual reality there's a bunch
of minigames on the drn's super it gives
you babes and
it gets a lot of play and it's super fun
funny to watch and to play so even if
somebody is just watching it
it's already entertaining enough for
them of course there are some other
games that are worth noting like the
serious same to last hope is for you and
your friend or whoever comes with you
you end up on the planets and you're
being moved from one planet to another
you're being given a certain weapons and
you just blast a bunch of enemies that
are running your way it's not really
like scary game it's more like a
slightly spooky I would say it has tons
of power-ups over time when you
basically you score the points after you
kill the monsters and then you can buy a
new and bigger guns more ammunition more
power-ups so that one is getting a lot
of play in it's very popular restored oh
okay
so it's also cool hearing from you not
only like the variety of VR applications
for entertainment which just seems like
the entertainment is gonna like kick it
off fast and then it's gonna get more
into industry and whatnot as well but
there's also it's kind of interesting
you also have really like those multi
hundred thousand dollar camera sets and
the CGI and all that stuff so they're
kind of both the bottoms picking up fast
but the tops also continuing to become
more and more cutting-edge as being
pushed over time and then so there's
also a difference between what VR people
are coming into play and then what the
normal like social gamers are coming in
for PC and Xbox one are the big ones you
also have a laser tag going on we'll get
to laser tag in a bit which is even a
bigger work out then VR is so on them on
PC and Xbox one a lot of kids are coming
into play for tonight I mean there's a
just a obviously a ridiculous money of
the League of Legends right so like yeah
so walk us through what they're coming
into play they have the gaming market is
extremely tough currently
like yes it's a multi-day they called
multibillion-dollar industry but at the
very same time there are just so many
games to choose from so it's it's it's
kind of like a rough market for a
publisher slash developers to even bring
the games because no one knows how well
it's gonna sell because the market is
oversaturated with cheap or absolutely
free games and right now there are two
free games that just dominate the rest
of the games and that would be fortnight
in epics legends a fortnight is
obviously everybody knows by now
probably developed by Epic Games and
they have their own software
distribution system there are so many
distribution systems now - like back in
the days team 14 years ago it was just
steam now we have steam you have ubisoft
you play that's another one that's
digital softer distribution system there
is epic launcher there is a Bethesda
launcher this is not sure why they
decided to start offering they own light
sure it was not the greatest idea
because what's the point everyone we
only have like five games to choose from
I don't know
I think Wizard answer blizzard yeah
Blizzard had they own for a while again
they they don't have as many games it
kind of it kind of actually probably
does the opposite for them because
currently they're called Blizzard
Activision or Activision Blizzard and
all the newest Call of Duty titles are
being released strictly on Blizzard app
that means you cannot obtain it on Steam
and a lot of people just refuse to
purchase it on Blizzard or even start
their own account they just will not
leave or they will not let off the steam
you can if you're if you're once if your
computer is powerful enough you could
stay log it into Steve you can you can
you know just dis a few still they
refuse to have too many lectures because
right now if the people are being pushed
because they want to be their own
everyone wants to have their own he
electroform law emerging this logging
into the dole this that's what the
absence of it looks like the social
accounts Facebook Twitter Linkedin
Instagram is just like that yes everyone
wants to have their own so be their own
platform and stuff yeah which is which
is severe not not the best idea like a
identity that's Hulu Amazon HBO there's
the same thing on videos except we're
talking more like a distribution for a
game for sketches people Wednesday when
once they were very comfortable and in
you know like a heaven 1 or 2
distribution software accounts they
don't really feel like negan or and I'm
not even talking about leaving then
don't feel like making another one on
top of this like I personally I do have
Blizzard account I have steam I have
origin origin that's another big one and
I actually strongly believe that or
there isn't
Bradley field sales or aren't as good on
PC or I should say bad because I
remember the year when it was first
released battlefield 2 there is we were
running out of licenses for the game we
had to get like 40 accounts for it but
then when battlefield 3 got released
even 10 copies were not getting played
and at that time the game was being
released on Origin client people just
didn't want to make their own accounts
for it and they were forcing everybody
to get the client to be able to buy the
battlefield so like I'm already playing
the game and you want to get your client
if you throw a buy it instead of just
down
no you-you-you do
I mean you buy it and you download it
but you still have to go through the
hassle of creating your own account and
hold on like this so how about when you
have something how many total stations
do you have right now on Picon for PC we
have our over the years our PC number
like originally started from 20 it went
to 40 and then I would say more like due
to the lack of space the consoles were
in more demand we started out with like
eight consoles at some point the number
of consoles essentially increased
currently we have 34 consoles and we
have 28 pcs so we have to go see big
numbers yes we have to bring the number
of PCs down so let's so let's explore
this so then when you have let's say you
like these kids want to come in and play
like League of Legends or for night or
mad and there's so many possibilities
right and you're talking about like you
having their own specific licenses right
you have the mold like if they want to
if ten people want to play League of
Legends but you only have like eight
licenses purchased that take oh how does
that work it's that one is actually
pretty simple for for a lot of these
games that are free we don't have to
provide any licenses at all they just
you just log in with your own account
and you're good to go
what about when there are like licenses
when it's a license for example games
like Battlefield for instance where
would you have to pay 60 per license
that you have to pay 60 per license we
don't get any discounts on the games we
don't get free games either so usually
we have to pay the full price on games
and even though we're basically like a
spot where the games get exposure for
developers slash publishers very often
the they don't think that we have any
effect on on a bottom line so they're
like well when we
we don't really have any interest and
working with the gaming centers but
monster works with you the energy drink
monster do to a certain extent just a
little bit so there's some at least some
people see the value anyway yeah yeah
yeah okay so then what happens with like
battlefield and like like what the bezel
field licensee system we have a software
license management system in place in
some a third party yes in Manaus it's a
it's a software that we basically were
one of the sponsors of it was developed
by one company and basically what it
does is let's say if you have 30 pcs and
you only have ten licenses for
battlefield game it will automatically
distribute those license keys slash
accounts to the to the machines running
and once you reach number ten you all
stop doing that
yeah that's once when somebody stops
playing the game it will instantly
become available again yes so somebody
else can forget it yeah that's cool so
but how do you know how many licenses to
buy for a game you know what popularity
means it's just yeah you just based on
popularity if you see the game is
getting more play and you keep running
out of licenses constantly it's easier
to add yeah just buy more games just
find more licenses and then put into the
management system yes and it'll
distribute it that's pretty cool so then
okay so you have to have a management
system that has all of the games plus
all the licenses that is constantly
being tapped into as people want to use
it or get lock out of it log into a new
game it's a pretty complicated system
you guys also have some extreme internet
speeds 500 megabits per second up and
down yeah we started with 20 megabits
download speed back in 2005 rate was
right around 5 megabits per second so
like when we moved to our forest
location
we decided to bump up the speed a little
bit and we were able to to get a pretty
decent price and for it to even though
it's still really allowed like our built
and probably country people yes from
when it was before like before we our
internet speed was 215 megabits per
second down in I believe 25 up on a
cable modem yeah
and now it's all fiber optics that's
great that's now a fiber optics business
business line 500 up and down yeah it's
so fast so you can handle can can you
then handle like all you have you know
about let's say 60 total like units
consoles look we can't handle all not
dealing with this kind of a speed
technically you can handle even 300 you
consoles or pcs simultaneous yes right
yes that's pretty crazy they don't use
as much as people normally think like
they you do use a lot of speed
connection speed when you download
patches or download the games but when
you actually are in the game normally
you never go you never go more than 5
megabits down at the same time in the 1
megabit up usually that's the top per
system how did you initially in 2005
even decide that you want to get
involved with this who were you growing
up that also got you interested in
gaming well I mean I was kind of a gamer
myself when I when I was in school and
when I went when I was in college we
were hosting a lot of LAN parties and
that that did seem like it was some an
extremely fun that's what people really
enjoy doing and at that at the time
it was kind of like a right timing for
that as well there was a lot of games
coming out around 2005 we had a new
counter strike source being released
will have battlefield 2 being released
so those were all major titles that were
very promising at that time not a lot of
people could afford a really nice gaming
systems so the business concept was
basically just to rent the system's out
to users and they would come in and play
together it was very unexpected
like a at that time the pricing was
about $4 per hour or you can get three
hours for I believe ten dollars by then
so it wasn't expensive we're already
doing land parties and this is popular
let's just make it into a business and
and host our land parties in there and
then see if other people want to come
well anything it wasn't no I would not
say it was like we were already making
all empires the last time I was I was
was involved in hosting a LAN party
before that was probably 1999 okay this
was popular yes I knew it was popular
and I knew it was something that people
would probably enjoy doing considering
the lack of entertainment in the city
yeah he couldn't really do much I mean
the city size was big enough to sustain
this kind of business
yeah model but probably only one galaxy
gaming like year seven yeah I would say
I would say so so like there was of
course a competition that magically
opened up just a week after we opened or
they'd gone now yeah there we go no it
was gamers computer gaming center they
were they were in a better location than
us like I when when I originally opening
and going through the business plan I
didn't want to risk at the same time so
much so I decided to opt out for
[Music]
kind of like okay location from the
business in the residential area which
later kind of I mean later I have
noticed that it was probably not the
best idea to do it this way the
competition opened up across from movie
theater yes they were constantly packed
and then it create created this vibe
overall that they were the first and we
just kind of like open afterwards but
that was completely different there I
mean you could you could actually say
that we open at the same time because
it's just a week apart but they only
last for a little over three years and
then ended up closing I think they had
some management issues and whatnot
because according to some customers
there was not a lot of equipment that
wasn't like up kept well yeah yeah so
you were constantly then you have to
constantly then either update in like
you know purchase new graphics cards or
premieres new processors purchase new
licenses you're constantly man how does
this you know this is a tough business
model you know you have to buy all the
equipment but then you have to
constantly basically every year you have
like a big you know more licenses more
graphics cards more process but you're
also selling the older ones so that
you're like you know you have an
ecosystem at least two other people
yourself yeah yeah well you don't
actually have to change the hardware as
often as you might think every where are
we five years yeah somewhere around like
thirty five years that would be a fair
estimate as far as the games go you'd
already have to buy the games like we
don't really have to buy the games I'm
not freaking
when when the games that you're
essentially buying cars
like the years they took us money but
when they don't get played as much as
the free games then you start 3 million
like why do we even need to offer these
games yeah when they don't get as much
play it anyway yeah yeah like the the
Gears of War 4 is a good example when I
played was three you hear three years of
war it's highly acclaimed game and and
it's consistently get an extremely high
scores everywhere on the reviews all it
was doing on our store is just
collecting the dust nobody would touch
this interesting yep it didn't it didn't
matter
Gears of War two three or four people
just did not have an interest here in
our store when did you incorporate later
check what here laser tag when were
moving toward a third location who's
doing by century theaters yes kind of
like in that area I decided that it was
it was a time to introduce another type
of attraction for somebody that might
not find gaming as appealing basically I
was looking for attraction that you
can't really replicate at home game and
you still can replicate at home you're
just not gonna I mean of course you
can't have six Xboxes at home or six
gaming pcs but not everybody needs one
like there is a lot of people that
instead of going and being social
they're just playing at the basement and
they don't don't go out just stay and
talk to their friends on the mic so and
that's that was the time when the mic
and basically online gaming has been
becoming extremely popular versus the
year 2005 around that time a lot of land
features of the games were actually
started getting removed from the games
like you could you could still join
people over the internet but on a local
area network it started going away what
was it that is because the Internet has
become
more accessible for everybody in
2004/2005 not everyone had a decent
connection speed to be able to play at
home so that was obviously one of those
things but as times went by everyone had
access to the fast internet connection
and it was right around 2008 2009 at the
very same time when we were moving :
unlike our name back then used to be
galaxy LAN Center it was based local
area network name and the feel of that
started fading away because there was
like lamb what does it even mean anymore
so and especially when considering an
introduced and laser tag to the Syrian
it it was just I felt it was a good idea
to change it to galaxy gaming I think
the only only other later take center
with gecko bees yes but but then but by
the time that were actually opening the
new vacation giggle base was already
closed down yeah they were using a very
old laser tag air it was basically a
laser tag from the ad and laser tag I
mean it it has its own history at some
point I would say sometime between like
2000 to 2012 somewhere on there the
laser tag has been going through some
rough times because they I mean
everybody remembers how goofy those guns
look like they look goofy and that's
kind of a year and
and in general the Sarah would always be
some some spaceship which was like that
the idea has become so old and people
just like yeah it would get old pretty
fast how did you pick your temper theme
that that's another thing when we were
opening a tooth that the provocation in
2010 because of the game and part of the
business we wanted to be appealing to
the gamer crowd as well and also at that
time call of duty serious games were
extremely popular so this is a decision
was made to make it more like I
realistic combat scene where it was even
the weapon that were using was called
battlefield life it's Australian company
that designs completely independent guns
like they are not connected to the laser
tag system like they're not connected to
the special software they just go after
radio signal there are some drawbacks of
course like you don't really get to see
in the scoreboard so you're not going to
have that and there was also a
limitation and what kind of gameplay
scenarios you can do so we would always
be stuck with the mission that in Call
of Duty it was called Search and Destroy
here single bugger yeah it was basically
a team elimination that's what they were
playing and fortunately or not a lot of
people were liking this this mission
because if you're not if like if you're
not a very good player and laser tag you
will get discouraged pretty fast and
easy because you will rush you'll get
sit out and wait until the game is over
exactly so even though it was I mean for
that time it was really cool the guns
were looking very realistic they looked
and felt and sounded like the real guns
it daytime kind of came to the end as
well the arena we felt it needed some
change like we looked at who the
customers were
mainly and we did like for the customer
crowd we had a lot of younger kids
coming in so we decided to look for
something that would appeal to both
adults and kids at the same time and
that was the Delta strike equipment
which we ended up getting they it they
don't look too goofy they look actually
fairly modern but at the same time
they're very safe they have like a
rubber noses there are not heavy so
they're fairly light and they just I
mean they just look and sound cool when
you use them they also have tons of
different gameplay scenarios even though
zombies and that's what people like of
course the the most play we see is the
team deathmatch or Delta one shot is
basically just like go in and you just
stop shooting everybody and at the end
of the game you will you will see the
total scores so basically even if you're
not the greatest player you're not gonna
get discouraged because even if you get
eliminated you're back in the game and
about five seconds or so once you're
gone hit points get restored
automatically you're back in the game
but at the very same time we wanted to
go with some in a much cooler for the
design of the arena itself I decided to
incorporate both ancient city and the
jungle the company originally offered
either jungle or the ancient city but I
feel like we with the size of the arena
we should blend in both and that's what
we ended up doing and people are really
like and what we did yeah ancient city
jungle themed laser tag it's really cool
it's also it's also very unique because
even if you go to Minneapolis Omaha or
Des Moines you will not find this kind
of a design you will not this kind of a
quality of the arena itself it's
completely interactive
it has video base stations which
essentially are interactive power-ups so
you just come up to one and if it has
any powerup available like energy shield
or a rapid fire you sure it and your gun
instantly instantly gets it you don't
have to actually like physically press
any buttons so that's where you know
that it's interactive completely yeah if
you shoot at certain objects in there
like we do have targets you also see the
effects come off as well as getting
extra points so that's what makes our in
a very unique and the capacity is also
pretty impressive our old one we can
only have 16 players in a new one we
have three guns 10/15 yeah you can go
1515 but with this software that we have
it allows us to have up to nine teams
simultaneously so if some business comes
in groups of three users giving your
loops of three like different
departments or just like a groups of
people coming in just like random
walk-ins on the weekends we can put them
all on different teams if we want to
that's cool yeah nice this is cool this
is like the really it's the future of
immersive experiences yes a lot of
people are really pumped about that type
of yeah people do enjoy when like when
you do get more immersive experience
people do enjoy that a lot and it kind
of shows like we were getting extremely
busy
the moment that we opened up you know we
had a lot of return in traffic as well
location it was open February 22nd yep
yep so just six months initial six
months in congrats you know people are
loving it
I mean it actually I got I really liked
knowing
fact that our arena that actually
basically became a like a landmark in in
a city so you can tell that so false
actually has a better arena than any
bigger series on the quad states yeah at
least that's how it is currently yeah
good job good job that's so cool and
it's it's also nice to see the kids
coming in and have passing fun time
together this type of stuff I want to
ask you this question because there's so
much backlash that's currently going on
around like gaming in general and some
people say it's like the worst form of
escapism and all this other kind of
stuff and I come I come to the defense
you know I care a lot about nuance so
yeah there's some people that are just
choosing to live in like most of their
time in like virtual realities which is
like okay sure they're doing that maybe
they don't want to learn physical skills
in the physical world but at the same
time there's interesting skills that are
picked up from gaming there's a lot of
really like first of all your motor
skills and being able to like your
dexterity with your hands your motor
skills is to be able to find like really
tiny things that are happening on like a
screen and be fat for fast response time
to that if there's team tons of
team-based skills and objective based
skills that have to happen a resource
management that has to happen so I want
you to talk about like the benefits as a
mom yeah well the resource management
would be a big one there are some games
that are based around like how to how to
do the budgeting it kind of build
strategy of a lot of things you
basically don't don't learn at school
the resource management would be very
useful and there is a lot of games that
are like this obviously the
communication I teamwork would be the
biggest one biggest benefits in gaming
but of course the motor skills as well
depending on what kind of games you're
playing of course but yes so it's more
than just entertainment
you develop some
some management skills definitely it
also of course who will depend on games
that you have selected and we do have to
have quite a good selection of realtime
strategy games yes which is huge on
resource management the teamwork that
kind of stuff
then what about would you say is the
this like this proclivity that we have
to tend to play games that have like
weapons in them or that of us just
obliterating other you're talking about
well to me personally the violence and
in games of course you know it's natural
to see it and games it's a way for
people to like release some pressure to
blow off some steam so to speak because
it was an actual study and like I mean
of course every time there is some
shooting going on in a in a school or
else were they the basically thing let's
blame the games first let's blame games
it's a new seeker there's guns that are
being sold illegally to the apples
because the guy was playing call of duty
it's it's definitely not the case I
would say and like really serious world
repercussions with people dying it is
alright I do see I do see a lot of
adults in that have no clue a lot of
politicians are trying to blame a game
and as basically a part of the problem
oh it's how basically like they mean the
main reason in is that is what they're
trying to use as because the people that
play video games cannot set the support
from reality and
smart from truces you can yeah going to
suing in purchasing gone kids please yes
yeah plaques market conseils has way
more to do I think with this kids do
understand this like even the very
little kids understand that the game is
the game and reality is reality yeah
just because you play in the game no
one's gonna be jumping on the car and
driving people over like they do in GTA
they understand that this there are
consequences in reality this is why they
have a lot of fun doing all this in
games where do you think the motor
skills and the resource management all
these other things where do you think
they have most applicability to life the
resource management is teamwork where
discipline well
the resource management definitely will
have in your pocketbook yeah because I
mean though in in a game it's very
simple you waste your army in a game and
then you didn't you didn't care to to
harvest crops and then didn't care to to
to extract the coal from the mines and
you ended up with no money and now you
only have one soldier so that one I mean
you can you can obviously bring two why
because if you can't manage your
spending habits you can manage resources
is you gonna have the same results in
real life far as the team team working
which is which you have to do a lot in a
lot of in a lot of games and you have
and you have to do it in a lot of games
before it can actually be very useful at
workplace we even have some businesses
coming in to do it I teamwork and
actually play video games together like
they separate and groups and only play
against each other so there is all I
mean the team works has always been
important and a lot of business and a
lot of businesses so obviously you you
can benefit from from learning that and
games too
what was the other we did
motor skills motor skills it can be
useful of course it really depends what
you do for a living
yeah how about you're looking back in my
life I totally see how like motor skills
like the fast speeds have helped me so
much with everything else that I've been
doing and attention and these how you
find things like that's another thing
yeah like the bezel yeah these autumn
just sense it your sensitivity do cute
changes how about the reaction time
reaction timing yeah
how about um we were talking about
teamwork there's more and more games
that are like you know during teamwork
out the window like this with fortnight
this battle royale mode it's all about
individualism yeah and it's it's like
it's it's you only get one life mode
like you at you once you die you have to
wait until to respond until everyone
else and then everyone just slowly and
steadily is you know so you know is it
around 16 or a hundred or like there's
like bigger sizes it goes it's a
variance in terms of size of players and
then but the map sizes get smaller and
smaller as its closes off the map size
as the player count decreases so point
and then and then so so talk about this
like also tendency towards these like
individualistic game modes - yeah I mean
it no doubt they're our most popular
games right now
I'm not biggest fan of those kind of
games like I'm I'm never you'll never
see me play battle royale games
I usually just play a team-based games I
play games like Battlefield I still play
League of Legends where it's all about
teamwork
sorry I enjoy having a team to work with
so I would probably be the the wrong
person to ask you know these peoples
tendencies to merge you know what I
wanna
hear your thoughts on is where we're
moving with games like stellaris I like
I like that game because it teaches
people about like universe design or
civilization design it takes people
outside of planet Earth a little bit
even I think more than like other games
do where you're literally able to
simulate out universes and transit
between planets and stars and go and
explore the different evolutions of life
so it kind of broadens people's
perspectives away from just one
biological evolution around a star
mm-hmm what do you get wording what do
you see like stories like that can be
super expansive for people's creativity
and possibilities they can't be but the
person has to have like a will for a in
a capacity for imagination certainly
those games aren't as popular it's
almost like they're fro too much
information to handle and apprehend
interesting yeah so unfortunately those
games don't get played as much again we
do and we're talking the number of
people that are willing to play them
it's such small that we don't even know
for most but that kind of a game posited
you'd a trainer you have to keep in mind
the public attention span it's it's not
getting any higher it's actually getting
reduced like people lose the interest so
fast nowadays in things so the lone
strategy games just take too much day
time like the last game that was
somewhat close to the one that you just
described was spore and it was released
I think around 2008 or 2009 it was
getting quite a bit of play in our store
back then but then you know trends
change they do and so this juxtaposition
between what a game that has a
ridiculous amount of information versus
ones that are like in a sense these like
battle area
for tonight's they're really fast
they're really little bit of information
you just need to know how you know just
to find enemies and take them down and
trying to win that round and then go
there and play another round so this so
it's kind of like the style is going
with the attention span of the
civilization kind of interesting how
about with like the graphics increases
have been so profound over the last 50
years we went from just pong to these
photorealistic gameplays and we're going
we're talking about computer graphics
and all stuff yeah at the very beginning
does it feel like this itself is already
an 80 year long simulation for you like
an 80 year long virtual reality
experience for you no it does not and I
also have to add the monitors keyboards
mice TVs they're not going away don't
really think so yeah they're still
they're still gonna be there for a very
long time for like two decades I don't
know if it's gonna be for the two
decades but definitely for one at least
it's it just more like it's the most
convenient everything else they try to
come up with is usually pretty bad like
it's usually just some gimmick you
you probably remember about ten years
ago or so the TV makers were pushing
hard for the stereo like a stereo
glasses for the TVs remember that what
was on the TV's you know actually you
don't even remember this was on the TV
it's like a stereo effect where you put
like a stereo glasses oh my gosh yeah I
remember
cars yeah we we had some manufacturers
and included on the media
bring basically singing one to our store
and people would play with those like
yeah cool man that moves on to the next
one like those didn't last at all we
would try and have like a four-person
movie with my incest it has a wave I
would say it has a very unique market I
mean that that technology like you you
go to the movie and sometimes like if I
if I know the movie is gonna have a lot
of cool visuals I would probably choose
to go to the 3d I mean they call a 3d
more like a stare ammonia
I will go them but play it's it's not
something I would want to have at home
so it's exactly the same kind of a
concept with water monitors and you know
like they just not gonna have anything
they're not gonna have any glasses and
you just put on and and and play like
this just just to add to this the vr
gaming is completely different than an
actual like a traditional gaming yeah
you can't play a longer than one or two
hours yeah you will get tired that one
person tried I think being in VR for a
week or something and then recorded and
then like afterward you can probably
have some serious well it's a lot easier
you just think about this when you play
in a VR you get a lot more information
and then you you are receiving a lot
more information
you're completely there you get
information both eyes your brain is
getting tricked so it does with some
strain and so you do actually get tired
you get tired much faster than you're
just sitting and relaxing on your couch
and playing with a controller it's
completely different you just can't do
it for hours they already can do it for
us in a sense you're tricking your brain
into teleporting into a delivery I mean
it just being next to your eyes right
here you have little neck being right
next to your eyes it will like you will
get tired that is walking it guys are
tired you tube you're tricking your
brain supporting it yeah into so if
somebody thinks that
you know in five years we're not even
gonna have any consoles not gonna have
any pcs just gonna have a bunch of the
others in our store for example it's
simply not gonna be the case in 20 years
is gonna be such different stuff 20 here
is yeah we'll see do you you don't think
this is already a virtual reality or
simulation you feel like what do you
what do you how do you feel about that
concept elaborate a little bit more that
this our life is already a simulation or
already a mm-hm
you're talking about the virtual reality
is our life already
you know after you die are you gonna
just be like oh that was such a fun game
no I don't I obviously don't think they
don't know you think this is a product
of biological evolution that we have
consciousness yeah yeah yeah yeah just
over do some it's just evolution affair
at least that's my that's my personal
thing do you ever feel like that this is
one big like artistic expression of God
or creation or source or anything like
that with all of us being our own little
paint strokes on the canvas everything
like that
it does tell us more about your
relationship with that well I don't even
know where to begin
I mean of course I did I did starting a
lot of like history evolution yeah
dinosaurs and all that I mean it's just
never ending equation how we became what
we are and the world we came from and
I'm afraid we won't be able to answer
that in our lifetime so very there you
go
I mean after I I enjoy watching the
movies were they I mean like the one
that was actually really that really
impressed me was Prometheus and if you
push that one have you have you seen it
which I'm trying
Prometheus oh my gosh yeah it's very
underrated but it it it makes you wonder
all those questions like where we came
from if we were and then like so I wish
that were you multiple times I don't
know it just once when I went to YouTube
to see what others are saying about it
it's like and of course somebody has to
take it to the extreme
so like if we were designed by the
engineers or like if we were designed by
what was the race that they called there
I forgot Titans
maybe so they were did they were also
designed by engineers and then the guy
keeps going further and further so who
who might engineer some somebody made
some where it being a source
yeah and just like I mean it just gonna
be like a neverending story
but for me it's very hard to believe
that I you just came to be from like
this little explosion that made like one
sail became like and I'm not being flies
[Music]
you know like whenever I which some sort
of so to say documentary hey but yeah
you know like dinosaur era how like well
this is how we're just gonna prove you
that evolution actually goes on right so
they had this hedge gold right or I mean
some reptile and it just happened to
like like it just happened that he just
wanted to to immerse it so so much or
with with the environment let it started
changing colors over time like millions
of years passed by an antenna no it's
not true did Amelia does that yeah but
it's like they're trying to tell you
that it used to not be able to do all
this and then it was writing and
genetically mutated to be able to you
welcome kinetically my stage we've
genetically mutated a lot over the last
six million years yeah but we didn't I
mean if we're mutating right now by
using VR and yeah but remember like with
all those cool features that you know
like let's say the frogs they can grow a
leg you know if it gets like you think
they had enough brain power to do that
like aura or like they couldn't do it
before and a million years later I just
suddenly have it that's a long period of
time in genetics there's a lot of
interesting so you're saying the
chameleon for example if weird a
chameleon right you should like it used
to not be able to change the color then
too late prey yeah and then later like
and really wanted to do it in a survival
mechanism yeah yeah and the same thing
with those those there's sea creatures
that do the same thing they when they
latch onto a rock and they can change to
the same tour if the rock but right but
what basically the documentaries are
trying to say that they used to not have
disability yeah
well that's the general idea so like the
company is biology yeah you just
straighten one that one that's right
because that one's eventually yeah it's
just interesting doesn't song to you
know sure yeah a stick because like some
chameleon wanted to like start changing
colors right and then the competent
works changed a bunch of different
options and then the one that exists the
one that the one that lived on the
longest because they could do that
feature ended up propagating its genes
for in there that's the general theory
of it's a it's a theory because like why
this why this one can do it but the
other types that are like similar to
that can't like yeah yeah how about with
I just I'm curious about this question
now do you do you ever feel like our
disconnection
from nature from the air that we breathe
the water we drink the food that we eat
the love that we have for each other do
you ever feel like that disconnection is
the reason why we have so many of the
issues in our world well the human brain
is pretty complex so we do a lot of
unnatural things so it's kind of like a
I guess part of doing business way part
of the tree growing crooked out of the
planet which is all yeah yeah well you
know the the brain is very like the
human brain is extremely complex it is
there's a lot of things that can go
wrong with it arguably the most complex
thing and then the civilization remains
even more complex so how about what do
you think is the meaning of life meaning
life well that's a good question
and we every buddy tries to come up with
the own answer for this like to have the
on purpose to do good you know that kind
of thing but there is no proof currently
that there is any purpose of life just
to like live on and have basically
something that's left after you you're
gone you used to be part of like the
meeting is to leave something yeah
like kids or like we're like you also
have this interesting butterfly effect
that you've had on on kids and adults
that have come into galaxy gaming that
have had experiences with you that have
been then able to go and tell their
people hey I played VR or so interested
in or this laser take experience or
whatever you know so you're leaving
behind that well this er I mean
the business that were in and the way is
we're not selling like cool equipment I
mean oh yeah we do actually because we
do sell gaming PC's like a custom-built
ones but mainly what people leave like
what people remember when they leave
like the lived memories they buy they
delivered memories they live experiences
something that they have before it is
kind of like an interesting feeling that
knowing that he introduced people to
some some experiences in memory is
because I mean what you can't really
have much fun here definitely because
the the the weather and you know we
don't live in a you know I was like yeah
we don't really live in the most like
friendly environment here six months of
really cool temperatures yeah and then
two months of extreme heat and just in
general like I mean even in like in like
I've been traveling myself I can I do go
to Florida quite often but even they
don't really have specifically like a
very similar type of entertainment that
we do offer here like in I mean
technically were like when you look at
our business model or hybrid game and
sin / entertainment center you
definitely don't have anything like this
in San Francisco I'm not really sure we
don't have a combination of laser tag we
know PC yeah word are yeah we're
currently the only entertainment center
that is basically like a hybrid PC
console we are in laser tag I call
everyone row it's a really cool combo
yeah but I get I guess what I'm what I
was trying to say is that the
the memories we still have some kids
coming in that started coming in back
when we first opened and everyone still
has a lot of great memories from all
those days playing games together or
playing laser tag or experience and
virtual reality for the first time
reconsidering a second city to open you
know no it's it it it takes too much of
a personal approach but I don't think
that franchise in a world like having a
second location in a different city
would would be a great idea a lot of
this is a personal approach and if
somebody was to open similar like a
business that would be you know to this
you would have to invest a lot like a
personal approach there so like I don't
see this type of business succeed in if
you just have like basically like a
faceless corporation and it's definitely
not the business where you can get away
with you know being like a very simple
without any interaction kind of like
what you get and work done also Burger
King no I totally know it's it's it's
very personal approach and even like the
staff members that we have no one is
like alike yeah everyone is different
and customers do remember pretty much
every one of them you're creating
memories and leaving notes behind I love
that what about what should like I mean
just an example will
were basically the first ones in Sioux
Falls to introduce the virtual reality
to the community and a lot of people
like you'd be surprised how many people
never travel anywhere like don't live
the state so coming in to experience a
virtual reality in 2011 2018 or 2019 is
worth something yeah especially because
that they will likely remember that that
was the first place that they had
experience because in a decade when it's
all over the place you were the one that
helped first bring it to them which is
huge and hopefully it expanded their
creativity their their idea of what's
possible and that's a big part of this
too is leaving memories that expand
people's creativity their ability to
find meaning in and bring their full
gifts out to the world what about a
skill that you think kids and adults
should learn as we go into this crazy
exponential technology era don't lose
themselves in a social networks try to
communicate more in person and in our
days you've noticed more and more people
are just too attached to their phones -
too attached to the social networks more
than anything so that's kind of like I
mean I don't know if it's gonna it's
gonna change anytime soon but you may
have noticed like a lot of people don't
answer their phones anymore they prefer
texting or messaging and you lose out on
a lot when you actually not like talking
to somebody over the phone you don't
always get the full picture of what
they're trying to tell you so there is
definitely like a lack of communication
because of the I mean social networks
are obviously part of that what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world the most beautiful things and more
I honestly never thought of that
yeah I don't think I'd be able to answer
that question you can take your time
think about it okay
most beautiful thing in the world I've
were talking about like a visual I'll
probably see the view of our planet from
like a spaceship nearby so something
along those lines and why I don't know
it just it just gives you like a very
overall picture of of what we are so so
to speak I mean it's kind of hard to
explain why I think um you know that
specifically this picture here I guess
is because it probably shows life yeah
it's the famous overview effect photo
when we first saw the earth yeah from
space it was like everyone has that we
ever know has lived it you probably have
you have probably seen like that is a
like what I really enjoyed there is what
we did really enjoy watching and so it's
a time lapse of of the earth like shows
basically like a nine-time all the
lights on it yeah that's really cool or
just yeah so I love that the earth is
lit the other half is at night with the
lights and then it just moves so fast
man and it also shows how tiny it is it
shows a tiny Baracus
even though it's huge - so tiny an 8
billion of us now on and hopefully we
can expand more move hot more
consciousness more meaning more
creativity birth more people out into
the cosmos like all these games now a
lot of them are about that so this was a
lot of fun I feel like you know we went
all over the place on gaming and you
know and your chin your life and
trajectory of bringing this forward and
meaningful experiences you've brought
people max thank you for joining us on
the show hey that's my place to be huge
pleasure yeah thank you thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also have more conversations with your
friends or families co-workers people
online about gaming and about the future
of gaming about virtual reality about
laser-tag about really cool meaningful
experiences being able to bring those to
people around the world faster check out
the links in the bio below of the galaxy
gaming comm also their Instagram
Facebook and Twitter profiles check
those out support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations that you believe in
support simulation our links are below
our paypal cryptocurrency patreon links
are down there also you can design call
merch and get paid all that is down
there and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]